so for a bear you deserve it to Barry
and iris
[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my
episode 5 video it was mostly a killer
frost episode even though there was a
subtle arrow crossover going but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a new giveaway stuff at the end
of this too so top 10 WTF comic book
Easter eggs starting with number 10 the
big arrow crossover before the four-way
crossover Felicity came on probably her
greatest contribution in my mind was
making all those Incredible Hulk jokes
so even though I try to think dc-to-dc
references The Incredible Hulk metaphor
for Cailin actually works perfectly like
they're both afraid of each other but if
you've seen Thor Ragnarok you know that
that relationship has changed it gives
you an idea for where Caitlin's
character is headed they did make a lot
of jokes about felicity wedding stuff oh
the last time we tried to get married
oliver was shot with an arrow i think
that was a cupid episode where they were
pretending to get married she actually
wore a wedding dress and i think it was
in season 4 it was a while ago it
doesn't seem like that long ago but it
was actually a couple years ago but
number 9 we get the barry powerpoint we
get to see them as kids they got married
as children they just want to show you
that they've been so close their entire
life you can imagine that theme music
from The Wonder Years playing in the
background and even though the episode
was largely about the craziness of the
night and the emergence of killer frost
they still did tie in a bunch of thinker
stuff like at the beginning of the
episode where they say we need to track
down to vote there are thousands of
Devoe's do you know any killer babies
that's a reference to baby Darkseid
who's been a big thing in the comics
this past year since they resurrected
him it's part of this big comic book
plot that has nothing to do with the TV
shows but it's become a really funny
thing lately with baby Darkseid Batman
recently pulled him right out of his
utility belt but number 8 welcome back
Hiller Frost so they have the first big
bite with Amunet black's man the
blacksmith you saw that little tag at
the end of last week's episode so it's
all just meant to push Kaitlyn into a
situation where she has to use her
powers because Incredible Hulk style
she's totally afraid of killer frost
because we actually learned through the
course of the episode that she doesn't
remember what happens while she's killer
frost even though I don't totally
believe that but as long as the flash TV
show sticks to its rules about who's in
charge when she's killer frost like
what's going on inside her head then
I'll be fine with it
as long as there can
with that but the bigger thing is that
she was actually booking a ticket on
fares air you know obviously green
lantern and reference to another city
because she knew somebody that could
breach her to another earth where she
didn't have to worry about being Kaitlyn
or killer frost it just wouldn't be a
big problem for her but the thing that
really tripped me up on that is I'm like
wait a minute who do we have in this
universe that can breach her to another
earth because the only people we know
that are capable of that are Cisco gypsy
speedsters there aren't any other
speedsters besides Barry and Wally on
this earth and Cisco probably wasn't the
person she was talking about in gypsy is
on earth 19 right now so apparently
there's someone else out there that can
breach to another world but here's where
it gets really wacky because there are
some rules for breaching like you have
the breach room down that like with the
big portal but people who have specific
metahuman breaching abilities like Cisco
gypsy and gypsies father they can breach
anywhere they want to so it's implied
that Caitlin knows another breacher
somewhere on earth one we don't know who
that is but number seven the seals
daughter is a stripper I totally was not
sure what they were going to do with
that character when she showed up at the
beginning of the episode question
answered pretty quickly and it's all
just meant to make Joe feel a little bit
better about being an old dad like it's
weird the way they're working her in she
might return during the back half of the
season if things heat up with the baby's
storyline that gets a little more
complicated we'll have to talk about
this Cecile baby because they're
spending so much time on it but it's
like a completely separate plotline from
what was going on in this episode so you
just have a lot of funny moments the way
they pitched the episode is that this
was going to be a situation whereby the
girls had to save the day
because something had happened to Barry
and turns out that something is interest
getting super drunk using Cisco special
sauce so I felt like the logic was fine
like the whole point was a Barry would
not be able to help so however you want
to justify that he was too drunk to
become the flash that's why they took
the cellphones away so he just sort of
turned into this funny moment of the
elongated man being a total dirtbag like
he's the number one customer of the
golden booty strip club he steals
people's money using his powers he's
still pretty despicable but he's not
that bad he'll probably have a moment
later this season like Caitlin had in
this episode where the bad
part of him actually does something
really good like oh I'm gonna be a hero
use my powers for good but there were
all kinds of speedster puns when Barry
got drunk on the flash run it off
because I'm the flash he even made a
Titanic joke they make a lot of Titanic
jokes because Victor Garber was
literally in the Titanic movie so
anytime you hear them make a reference
to that on legends of tomorrow or one of
the other TV shows it's just them poking
fun at Victor Garber but number five
meet the blacksmith Katee Sackhoff was
great as that character if you're
wondering why she was using a British
accent because if you've seen her in
anything else you know that she's not
British so it was kind of weird the
first time she opened her mouth it's
because the comic book version of the
character is British so she's probably
just trying to be true to form in pretty
much everything about her character is
accurate to the comics they talk about
the underground market that's the
version of the network that she runs in
the comics so that actually happened
during a thinker arc so it makes sense
that they wanted to bring this character
on to the flash during this season is
one of the big rogue leaders so I don't
think that she has any direct connection
to the thinker other than the use of the
bus metahuman who excreted those tears
that they turned into a drug so it's not
like she's working directly with the
thinker but maybe they'll try to tie
them together by the end of the season
or maybe she'll just come back for a
one-off episode but if you were confused
this is one of the people that was on
the bus so that's why the thinker
collected him at the end of the episode
you can make all kinds of Riverdale
jingle-jangle jokes because you have
Diggle on arrow taking drugs now you
have this special drug source here on
the flash the Amunet black is sort of
running this underground drug ring and
you have all that stuff going on on
Riverdale so you use the Riverdale
jingle-jangle theory that everything is
connected so number four obviously
killer frost versus blacksmith round one
she gets her ass handed to her she goes
back to being Catelyn they have like a
really nice moment with Iris it was a
pretty good fight the second fight was
way better because it's a good
opportunity for us to see a whole bunch
of new Caitlin killer frost powers but
the funny thing about that talk that she
had with Iris they were poking fun at
some of the history between the
characters in mostly that there was no
history like we haven't spent that much
time hanging out we haven't become
friends even though they've both been
series regulars on a TV show for the
past three years so which is the writer
being funny about the fact that they've
never actually had those characters do
anything together in all these years but
now she's gonna be one of the
bridesmaids they said that they're gonna
hang out so you just probably see more
scenes with the two of them just doing
random stuff when they're not with the
flash but number three was stripper
SummerSlam and them getting thrown in
jail that was pretty funny I mean it
depends on how funny you think stuff
like that is I felt like they did a good
job of not drawing it out it was a fun
excuse to throw Joe in jail like he has
his own big moment as Barry's throwing
up in the toilet I'm afraid of being a
dad I'm almost 50 years old what the
hell's going on but the next big one was
obviously that killer frost called to
action at the end of the episode where
she you know the transition is pretty
cool they spent most of their CG on that
final big scene which is why they
probably did have big killer frost
scenes earlier in the episode but she
uses a big area of effect frost breath
she makes a frost dome to stop the
bullets so it's just a way to show you
some new abilities that she's developed
before we get to the four-way crossover
because she will be full-blown killer
frost for most of that but again the
episode was mostly intended to be you
know girls night out girls try to solve
the problem of the episode which is
Amunet black but hilariously get
themselves into trouble forcing Caitlin
to become killer frost again which is
kind of like a Hulk moment during the
thor ragnarok movies so no spoilers for
that movie if you haven't seen it yet
but there's a very similar moment to
what Caitlyn did at the end of the
episode where she has to become killer
frost again but number one is obviously
that thinker post-credits tag where he's
like I went through the trouble of
creating you you can't die until you
complete the task for which you were
created implying that there's a reason
why all of them are coming together and
I think it has something to do with
challenging the flash and getting him to
do something as well like not only did
the thinker need Barry to come out of
the Speed Force to create the medes
he'll probably want Barry's abilities to
do something else even bigger later on
it sounds like he has a really sinister
plan for fixing humanity and turning it
into this weird perfect version of
itself but it'll be interesting to see
how close they stick to the comic book
thinker arc during the Jeff Jones era
because that was more of a matrix story
like he was almost uploading reality
into this matrix like simulation so
that's where things go a little bit
different so if you've read Geoff Johns
thinker arc it's not gonna be exactly
like that but just
number at the end of the episode where
blacksmith says I'll come back and ruin
something for you that's just her saying
that she'll be back probably in the
second half of the season sometime in
the spring but the only other real big
thing of note was that really long scene
with Cecile and Joe they're spending a
lot of time with those characters
because yeah they're being a lot more
positive and comedic this season but
there's always a reversal anytime they
linger on something in a really awkward
way like wow this is a really long scene
why is this going on so long so I know
everybody's thinking Daniel West
reverse-flash but it just remains to be
seen how quickly her pregnancy proceeds
in what they might do in the final
episodes of the season a lot of people
think that'll have something to do with
the think or Ark and that does make a
lot of sense like maybe the baby will
have something to do with the thinker's
plan but let me know in the comments
what did you think of the episode
obviously it was a little bit weird
because it was a very different type of
episode than you would normally get
normally the flash is the person that
solves all the problems but next week's
episode is the Council of Welles
episodes so you can think of that in
terms of the Council of reeds like you
know they had a bunch of different
versions of Reed Richards from the
multiverse you could think of it in a
council of ricks Rick and Morty Way but
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video congratulations to the winner from
the last video
Orvil e^x please private message me so I
can get your contact details you can
click here for the teaser trailer for
the big four-way crossover and you can
click here to learn about Marvel maybe
crossing over with the x-men movies
eventually thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight